This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是真人。你有帮助他人真正改变现状的愿望吗？拉西特学院（The College La Cite）为你提供“依赖症与情感支持”专业。掌握
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health and dependents. Construise a career enriching to service
陪伴和支持面临健康与依赖问题的人群所必需的技能。打造一份丰富多彩的职业，为
of the community francophone of all the country. Don't the quality in French, it's possible
全国各地的法语社区服务。无需法语极其流利，这一切在
with the City. Visit Collage LaC. .A. today, An initiative of the Consortium National
La Cite学院皆有可能。今天就访问CollageLaCite.ca。这是加拿大卫生部（Santee Canada）支持的
of Formation in Health Supposed by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder
国家健康培训联合会的一项倡议。那些眼睛里毫无生气。它们变成了黑色。吓死我了。恶魔，醒醒。我是那个亲眼目睹克里瓦克和德皮波
take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey
行凶杀人的女性。安东尼·德皮波被判处最高刑期时，毫无悔意，显得无动于衷。我说，我没有罪。我将为此奉陪到底。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《博恩瓦利的魔鬼采石场》。快乐至关重要，它也同样难以捉摸，但现在有一种全新且令人兴奋的方式来开启你的旅程，
toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
去追求更加快乐的生活。趣味101（Joy 101）。这是一档由我——霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotb）主持的全新播客。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的空中聊天。打开你的免费iHeart Radio应用。搜索Joy 101并立即收听。由CVS为您呈现的霍达·科特比主持的《趣味101》。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nand-es,
每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我首先是一个人。自我出生以来，每一天我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情感共存。这不是一档普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。这只是关于生存意味着什么的坦诚对话。我是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯（Javier "Chicharito" Hernandez），
and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Your husband is not who you think he is. Your body is not what you thought it was. Your identity is formed by a secret history. I'm Danny Shapiro. And these are just a few of the stunning stories I'll be exploring on the 14th season of Family Secrets.
在iHeart Radio、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。你的丈夫并不是你所想的那样。你的身体也不是你原以为的那样。你的身份由一段秘密的历史塑造。我是丹妮·夏皮罗（Dani Shapiro）。而这些只是我将在《家族秘密》第14季中探讨的众多惊人故事中的一小部分。
He kind of shoved me out of the way and said, move. And he went out the front door and he jumped in a car and drove off. And that was the last time I saw him. Listen to Season 14 of Family Secrets. secrets on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast.
他有点把我推开，说，让开。然后他走到前门，跳上一辆车，开车走了。那是我最后一次见到他。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《家族秘密》第14季。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克（Jemma Spiek），欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一档播客，我们将在其中探讨二十岁时面临的最大变化、重要时刻和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。
It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today, let's talk. about an exceedingly common anxiety and maybe unhappiness for many of us in our 20s, for many ages actually, let's be honest. And that is the depressing state of the nine to five life and our increasing disillusionment with this way of living. For so many of us who go to college or who just have like professional ambitions of any kind, it kind of feels like the nine to five is our professional destiny. There's no avoiding it. It's hard to as we try. And for all of its downsides, like it does offer structure. It offers the structure and the kind of work that most of us are told we should want and that would reward us. If you study hard,
非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目。今天，让我们来谈谈对于我们许多处于二十多岁的人来说，甚至老实说，对于许多不同年龄段的人来说，极其常见的一种焦虑，或许也是一种不快乐。那就是朝九晚五生活的压抑状态，以及我们对这种生活方式日益增长的幻灭感。对于我们当中许多上大学的人，或者只是有各种职业野心的人来说，朝九晚五似乎就是我们的职业宿命。这是无可避免的。尽管我们百般尝试。尽管它有种种缺点，但它确实提供了结构。它提供了结构以及大多数人被告知我们应该渴望并能回报我们的那种工作。如果你努力学习，
you get the degree, you get the job, you work your way up, you buy your apartment, you buy your house, like that's going to be a happy life. That's the blueprint. And if you don't love it, if you feel trapped by it, exhausted by it, very resentful of it, there's this assumption that maybe you're just lazy or you're ungrateful or you are expecting too much from your work life and it's unreasonable. But I actually don't think that's true. I think a lot of us are asking a very fair question, which is, why does a lifestyle we spend the majority of our adult years in so often feel deeply misaligned with how we naturally want to live? Do I just have to get used to this? Or is it actually that wrong to want more? Here's the thing.
你拿到学位，找到工作，一步步晋升，买下你的公寓，买下你的房子，觉得那将是幸福的生活。这就是蓝图。如果你不喜欢它，如果你感到被它困住、精疲力竭、充满怨恨，就会有一种假设，认为也许你只是懒惰、不知感恩，或者你对工作生活的要求太高、不切实际。但实际上我并不这么认为。我认为我们中的很多人都在提出一个非常公平的问题，那就是：为什么一个占去我们成年生活大部分时间的日常生活方式，经常会让我们感到与我们天生想过的生活严重脱节？难道我只能习惯这一切吗？还是说渴望得到更多真的是错的？事情是这样的。
I don't think the issue is always the job. It is the structure that it demands from us and the fact that for a lot of people, it will never be fulfilling. Just the very nature of that work is not fulfilling. So what's next? That's what we're going to discuss today. The three reasons why the nine to five may feel so unnatural for you personally. The personality factors that influence your tolerance or indeed your enjoyment of this lifestyle, how to love your life outside of your job using some very important psychological hacks. And I guess when it's time to risk it and try something beyond the traditional 9 to 5 work lifestyle and your plan, your exact plan for doing so from somebody, i.e. myself, who has done it. So stay with us. Why is it that our 9 to 5 can feel so
我认为问题并不总是在于工作本身。而是它对我们要求的结构，以及对很多人来说，它永远不会带来成就感这一事实。这种工作本身的性质就无法带来成就感。接下来是什么？这就是我们今天要讨论的内容。朝九晚五对你个人而言可能感觉如此不自然的三个原因；影响你对这种生活方式的容忍度甚至是享受程度的人格因素；利用一些非常重要的心理学诀窍来热爱工作之外的生活；以及我想，什么时候是时候冒险去尝试传统朝九晚五工作生活之外的东西，以及为你制定一份确切的计划——这个计划来自一个已经做过这一切的人，也就是我本人。所以请继续收听。为什么我们的朝九晚五有时会让人感觉如此
unnatural and foreboding at times? Basically, why does it feel like such a scam that we spend our entire lives in service of somebody else with a weekend and maybe four weeks vacation, if you're lucky, I know that's a very dramatic take to call the 9 to 5 life a scam, but I know it's a take that a lot of you have, and I think that's for a few reasons. Number one, it is never just a 9 to 5. It's an 8 to 6 if you include getting ready, and you'll commute. It's an 8 to 7 or 8 to 8 if you include overtime, maybe even longer. And then it's the fact that you're expected to be switched on and functioning for all those hours,
不自然且充满不祥预感？基本上，为什么我们会觉得，把一整生都奉献给别人，只换取一个周末和（如果幸运的话）四周的假期，是一个如此巨大的骗局？我知道把朝九晚五的生活称为骗局是一个非常戏剧化的看法，但我知道这也是你们许多人都有的看法，我认为这有几个原因。第一，它绝对不仅仅是朝九晚五。如果算上梳洗打扮和通勤时间，它是八点到六点。如果算上加班，可能是八点到七点或八点到八点，甚至更久。然后，在所有这些小时里，你都被期望保持高度专注和运转，
when we know that humans can only do focused intensive work for probably three to four hours max per day. And so that leaves us with very, very little energy to want or even to desire to do anything else when we get home other than each hour maybe watch a TV show. Because of the fact our 9 to 5 takes up the majority of our waking productive hours, it is very difficult to establish a personality beyond work because our motivation, our energy is depleted by the monotony of routine, meaning that friendships, hobbies, personal goals, like, those are the things that get deprioritized. This also has a secondary effect that I don't see many people talk about, which is that as our lives become more centralized around work, so does our mood, so does our emotional state.
而我们知道，人类每天可能只能进行最多三到四个小时的专注、高强度工作。因此，这让我们在回到家后，除了可能每小时看一集电视剧之外，几乎没有留下任何精力去想要甚至渴望做任何其他事情。由于我们的朝九晚五占据了我们绝大部分清醒且富有成效的时间，我们很难在工作之外建立个性，因为我们的动力和精力都被单调的日常消耗殆尽，这意味着友谊、爱好、个人目标等，都成了优先级降低的事情。这还产生了一个我没看到多少人讨论的次要影响，那就是随着我们的生活越来越以工作为中心，我们的情绪和情感状态也随之如此。
In psychology, this has a name. It's called identity fusion or role engulfment. It's a process wherein we lose ourselves to the roles we play as that role dominates over all other facets. at our sense of being. So basically, our 9 to 5, if we're not careful, it doesn't just steal our hours, it steals our identity. Now, what happens if your 9 to 5 then becomes really toxic? What if you stop enjoying work? Because that's fine if you're having a good time at work, but what if your boss or your co-worker becomes unpleasant? What if deadlines pile up? There's no escaping from that when work is all you have. And when you have nothing else beyond that if you have experienced role engulfment, you know, your interest, your purpose, your
在心理学中，这有一个名字。它被称为认同融合（identity fusion）或角色吞噬（role engulfment）。这是一个在这个过程中，随着角色主导了我们存在感的方方面面，我们迷失在所扮演的角色中的过程。基本上，如果我们不小心，朝九晚五不仅偷走了我们的时间，还偷走了我们的身份。现在，如果你的朝九晚五变得非常糟糕，会发生什么？如果你开始不喜欢工作了怎么办？因为如果你在工作得很开心，那倒无所谓，但如果你的老板或同事变得令人讨厌呢？如果截止日期堆积如山呢？当工作就是你的一切时，你是无法逃避这一切的。如果你经历了角色吞噬，除了工作之外别无他物，你知道的，你的兴趣、你的目标、你的
fulfillment becomes the job and you become, you become the job essentially. You know what also influences this? Definitely we get burnt out when we have too much to do. We also struggle when we don't have enough to do. There was a 2021 study that found that workplace and life satisfaction is equally influenced by being underworked as it is by being overworked. It's so hard to find, like just that sweet spot with a nine to five where you're like equally challenged whilst also not feeling like entirely dominated by work. The routine and I think just the system in itself is not designed to work in parallel to a fulfilling life because of that reason and because of many reasons, including reason number three, why your nine to five at time feels so unnatural. And that is
成就感就变成了工作，而你基本上就变成了、变成了工作。你知道是什么也影响了这一点吗？毫无疑问，当我们有太多事情要做时，我们会精疲力竭。当我们的事情不够做时，我们也会陷入挣扎。2021年的一项研究发现，工作和生活满意度同样受到工作不足和工作过度的影响。在朝九晚五中找到那个完美的平衡点是如此困难，即你既能受到同等的挑战，同时又不会觉得完全被工作所主宰。由于这个原因以及许多原因（包括第三个原因，即为什么你的朝九晚五有时会感觉如此不自然），日常琐事和我认为这种制度本身就不是为了与充实的生活并行而设计的。
that the 9 to 5 was designed for when people had a domestic partner to take care of all the other little things that life requires from us. The first 9 to 5, like 40-hour work week was introduced in like the 1920s, I think 1926, almost 100 years ago when almost 90% of men who were working age were married by the age of 40. Women traditionally did not work once they got married. They were only, I think they only made up a quarter of the workplace, meaning a 9 to 5 model at that time operated on the idea that most people, men, you know, had someone who could do the groceries, could maintain their home, could take care of the kids, could organize their lives. So you're basically at this point doing the job of two people and then you're expected to have a personality on top of
那就是朝九晚五是为那个时代设计的，当时人们有家庭伴侣来照顾生活对我们要求的其他所有琐事。第一个朝九晚五，比如40小时工作制，是在大约20世纪20年代引入的，我想是1926年，几乎100年前，当时几乎90%的工作年龄男性在40岁之前就结婚了。传统上，女性结婚后就不再工作了。她们只占职场的四分之一左右，这意味着当时的朝九晚五模式建立在这样一种理念之上：大多数人（男性）都有人可以去买杂货、维持家务、照顾孩子、安排他们的生活。所以，在这一点上，你基本上是在做两个人的工作，然后你还被期望在此之上拥有
it. An article I read from MIT actually found through historical records that pre-industrial workers actually had shorter days and work weeks than we do today. Back in those days, many people only worked like 150 to 180 days per year, according to UK historical data. They basically got a six-month holiday due to the agricultural seasons, due to church holidays, due to how wages and hours were structured. I think it's a common misconception that these days, like, we must have the most progressive working conditions and wages and hours of all time and that the 9 to 5 is basically just normal and natural because, of course, it is.
个性。我读过麻省理工学院（MIT）的一篇文章，通过历史记录发现，前工业时代的工人的工作日和每周工作时间实际上比我们今天还要短。根据英国的历史数据，在那些日子里，许多人每年只工作150到180天。由于农业季节、教会假期以及工资和工时的结构，他们基本上获得了六个月的假期。我认为这是一个常见的误解，即今天我们一定拥有史上最进步的工作条件、工资和工时，而且朝九晚五基本上只是正常和自然的，因为当然，
That's how it's always been. Research shows that it's not the most normal and natural, and it's not the way it's always been. I think the final reason our 9 to 5 can feel so stifling is because it's hard not to think eventually, like, is this all there is? Especially in our 20s. There is definitely a level of like existential fatalism
事情一直都是这样的。研究表明，这并不是最正常和最自然的，也不是事情一直以来的样子。我认为我们的朝九晚五会让人感到如此窒息的最后一个原因，是因为很难不去想最终：难道这就是全部了吗？特别是在我们二十多岁的时候。这里绝对存在一定程度的虚无主义宿命论，
that there's no escaping this system. Like at some stage, we start projecting forward and forward and realizing, hey, wait, I have maybe like 70 to 80 good years here. I'm 22, 25, 29 now. I retire at 65. I have 30 to 40 years of this left and then I get 10 years to like enjoy this and that's all. That doesn't sound fair nor does it sound like, you know, the dreams that you have as a child. Don't get me wrong.
觉得根本无法逃脱这个体制。就像在某个阶段，我们开始不断地向未来张望，意识到，嘿，等等，我在这里可能只有大概70到80个好年头。我现在22岁、25岁、29岁。我65岁退休。我剩下的时间里还有30到40年要过这种生活，然后我有10年的时间来享受这一切，仅此而已。这听起来既不公平，也不像你童年时曾有过的梦想。别误会我。
Like there are huge benefits to working a 9 to 5. I loved my 9 to 5 for many reasons. Number one being financial stability. Number two being just life stability and the structure and the predictability and number three being community and the people around you. And also the fact that like unlike working for yourself, when you leave the workplace, like when you go home for the day, for the most part, like you can switch off, right? Like you're allowed to leave because it's not like it's not your business on the line. There's definitely perks, right? I'm not trying to villainize the nine to five. But I do believe rather strongly actually that not everyone is meant to work a nine to five.
朝九晚五有很多巨大的好处。我喜欢我的朝九晚五，原因有很多。第一是财务稳定性。第二是生活稳定性以及结构和可预测性，第三是社群和周围的人。还有一个事实是，不像为自己打工，当你离开工作场所时，比如一天工作结束回家后，在大多数情况下，你可以切换状态，对吧？你可以离开，因为这不是你的生意在承担风险。这绝对有好处，对吧？我并不是在妖魔化朝九晚五。但我确实非常坚信，并非所有人都注定要朝九晚五。
Just like not everyone is meant to be a doctor or an actor or a priest. and not everyone is meant to work for themselves either. There are certain personalities that when it comes to this 9 to 5 lifestyle, they will never find fulfillment. There's no getting used to it, regardless of the job, the workplace, the boss, the pay, all the other factors. It is the structure that they have a problem with. One theory of why this is comes from Jungian psychology and the Jungian personality types.
就像并非所有人都注定要当医生、演员或牧师一样，也并非所有人都注定要为自己打工。对于这种朝九晚五的生活方式，某些人格类型将永远无法找到成就感。无论工作、工作场所、老板、薪水或所有其他因素如何，都是无法习惯的。他们有问题的是这种结构。对此原因的一种解释来自荣格心理学（Jungian psychology）和荣格人格类型。
So if you aren't familiar with Carl Jung's theories, he is essentially one of these. grandfathers of modern psychology and he believed that there are eight personality types and 12 archetypes that each person can essentially fall into. This has now been expanded like in the last 100 years to the 16 personality types, also known as your Myers-Brigg personality type indicator. That is based on Jung's work. I have to say there's been debate recently around the legitimacy of this categorization. We have a full episode on this. I think it's like our personality. test legit, you can go and listen to it. But if you do follow the theory, according to the 16 personality types, only four out of the 16 do well in a structured work environment. That is 25%,
如果你对卡尔·荣格（Carl Jung）的理论不熟悉，他基本上是现代心理学的泰斗之一，他认为每个人基本上可以分为八种人格类型和12种原型。在过去的100年里，这已经扩展到16种人格类型，也被称为你的迈尔斯-布里格斯性格分类法（Myers-Briggs personality type indicator）。这是基于荣格的工作。我必须说，最近关于这种分类的合法性一直存在争论。我们有一整集专门讨论这个。我认为大概是探讨我们的性格测试是否合法，你可以去听听。但如果你确实遵循这种理论，根据这16种人格类型，16种中只有4种在结构化的工作环境中表现良好。这占25%，
25% of people only who have the attitude, temperament and personality to thrive and enjoy this type of work. These are the, I think the logic, the defender, the executive and the console. basically they're like the sentinel personality types and these are the people who are practical they're highly organized they like tradition they like structured environments they're very self-motivated they do well in a nine to five the people who according to the Myers-Briggs research don't do well in a nine to five or don't find that it suits them are the analysts and the explorer types also known as our entrepreneurs entertainers debaters architect adventurers these aren't job titles, by the way, the names that they give to like the specific configuration of
只有25%的人拥有能够蓬勃发展并享受这种类型工作的态度、气质和人格。这些是，我认为是逻辑学家、防御者、执行官和领事。基本上他们是哨兵型人格（sentinel personality types），这些人非常实用，高度组织化，他们喜欢传统，喜欢结构化的环境，他们非常有自我驱动力，他们在朝九晚五中表现得很好。根据迈尔斯-布里格斯的研究，在朝九晚五中表现不好或发现它不适合自己的人是分析家和探险家类型，也被称为我们的企业家、表演者、辩论家、建筑师、冒险家。顺便说一句，这些都不是职位名称，而是他们给特定人格特质组合起的名字。
personality traits. And these groups represent those of us who are very independent, but also very spontaneous, very creative, very motivated. We can solve problems. We can work diligently. That's not the problem. We struggle to do that though when we're being instructed to do so, when we don't see the purpose behind why we've been asked to do it, when we don't care about what we're doing when the schedule that we have to do something by is set by somebody else. Signs that this may be you is that it's not the job that's annoying you. It's the structure around the job. You may love the industry you're in. You may love what you do. You just wish you could do it more independently or for yourself or you wish you could set your own hours. You wish you had
这些群体代表了我们当中非常独立，但同时也非常随性、极具创造力、充满动力的人。我们能解决问题。我们可以努力工作。这不是问题。然而，当我们被指示去做，当我们看不到被要求这样做的背后的目的，当我们不在乎我们在做什么，当我们必须做某事的日程由别人设定时，我们就很难做到这一点。这可能是你的迹象是：惹恼你的不是工作本身，而是工作周围的结构。你可能热爱你所在的行业。你可能热爱你所做的事。你只是希望你能更独立地做，或者为自己做，或者你希望你能自己设定工作时间。你希望对它如何影响你的生活有更多的发言权。我的朋友们，这就是为什么你，你可能有一份稳定的工作，你可能非常感激这份薪水，但对余生都要朝九晚五的工作这一整个想法完全幻灭。因为
more of a say over how it affected you in your life. This, my friends, is why I, you know, you may have a secure job, you may be really grateful for the paycheck, but still completely disillusioned by the entire idea of working in 9 to 5 for the rest of your life. Because because of the way it sits in contrast to how you see yourself and your future, what is the solution to that? Because it's probably not, just quit your job. That's too simplistic. It's like when people hear about your relationship problems and are like, just dump him. Like, yeah, get it over with, dump him. Like, that's not how it works, it's not how life works. At this stage, you have two options. You either have to find a way to tolerate the nine to five by making your life around it, bigger and grander, or you have to
由于它与你如何看待自己和未来形成鲜明对比，解决这个问题的办法是什么？因为可能不是“直接辞职”那么简单。这太简单化了。就像人们听到你的感情问题时说“直接甩了他”一样。是的，结束吧，甩了他。这根本不是那么回事，生活也不是这样运作的。在这个阶段，你有两个选择。你要么通过让你的生活变得更大、更宏大来找到一种包容朝九晚五的方法，要么你必须找到一个更符合你的愿望和人格的朝九晚五的替代方案，并向其过渡。我们将在短暂的休息后探讨这两种替代方案。请继续收听。你有帮助他人真正改变现状的愿望吗？拉西特学院为你提供“依赖症与情感支持”专业。
find an alternative to the nine to five that sits better with your desires and personality and make the transition to it. We're going to explore both of these alternatives after this short break. Stay with us. You have the desire to help to make a real difference? The College of the City you offer the program Dependance and Scenti Mental.
掌握陪伴和支持面临健康与依赖问题的人群所必需的技能。打造一份丰富多彩的职业，为
Acquare the competences essential for accompany and support the people confronted to to the difficulties of health and and dependents. Construise a career
全国各地的法语社区服务。无需法语极其流利，这一切在
enriching to service of the community francophone of all the country. Don't know of the quality in French, it's possible
La Cite学院皆有可能。今天就访问CollageLaCite.ca。这是由加拿大卫生部支持的
with the City. Visit Collage Lacit www.C.A. today, an initiative of the Consortium National
国家健康培训联合会的一项倡议。那一刻，感觉仿佛漫长得没有尽头。我以为我活不成了。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里毫无生气。它们变成了黑色。吓死我了。
of Formation in Sautenue by Sante Canada. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me.
那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，长官。可以毫不夸张地说，这是你职业生涯中最大的案子吗？是的，长官。针对儿童的强奸和谋杀。简直不能更恶劣了。我想是的。人们醒醒。
That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up.
亲眼目睹克里瓦克和德皮波行凶杀人。安东尼·德皮波被判处最高刑期时，毫无悔意，显得无动于衷。我说，我没有罪。我将为此奉陪到底。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《博恩瓦利的魔鬼采试场》。要在苹果播客上收听无广告且包含独家内容的《博恩瓦利的魔鬼采石场》，请订阅Love for Good Plus。
and saw the murder take place by Creveit and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts.
播客《由霍达·科特比主持的趣味101》的主持人。我们将一起与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话。就像女演员奥利维亚·穆恩（Olivia Munn）分享她是如何克服严峻的健康挑战时说的。我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过了乳腺癌。那更困难。有很多人理解产后抑郁症。但我对产后焦虑毫无准备。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听由霍达·科特比主持的《趣味101》。
The host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer. And that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这真是太让人兴奋了，因为他们的全新明星是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我首先是一个人。自我出生以来，每一天我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情感共存。而且我仍然有那么多的疑问。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何应对被取消？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？
And it's a ton of exciting because their new star is Javier T. Torito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa?
从日常平凡到深刻极端。这不是一档普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。这档播客就像是与你最亲密的朋友进行深入交谈，脆弱感流露无遗。阴谋论被摆上台面，目标和教训被提出。生命中的一切，都有着完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。等等我，我在这里，我要去能够去连接。小豌豆。
From every day and ordinary to the deep and extreme. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shot. All in this life, has an order perfect and everything is just. Wait me, I'm here to put me going to be able to be able to connect. The Chicharito.
哦，哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯，与iHeart Radio一起，我们将把平凡变得不凡。敬请关注。在iHeart Radio、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Champs》播客中，我们将与文化界最红的名字对话，比如斯韦·李（Swae Lee）。你意识到自己有多传奇吗？我很感激。我看到了，但我会想，天哪，我还有好多、好多事情要做。
Oh, Javier El Chicharito Hernandez, and together with Iha Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac. to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do.
就像王子（Prince），他发行了大概30张专辑。我们现在才发行了大概五张。这就是我们前进的速度。是的，这态度不错。你还将听到来自行业传奇和嘻哈先锋的故事，比如法布 5·弗雷迪（Fab 5 Freddy）。我执导了纳斯（Nas）早期的一部音乐录影带。哪一部？
Like, Prince, he dropped like 30 albums. We dropped, like, five right now. Like, that's the rate we got to be going. Yeah, that's a good attitude. You also hear stories from industry legends and hip-hop pioneers like Fabric. 5 Freddie. I directed when the Nas' early videos. Which one?
《One Love》。哇。我真的在他在昆斯布里奇（Queensbridge）的公寓里拍摄的。他妈妈当时还在那个公寓里。纳斯才刚刚开始崭露头角。他爸爸以前住在我在哈林区（Harlem）附近。他爸爸向他介绍了很多，你知道的，
One love. Wow. I literally filmed in his apartment in Queensbridge. His moms were still up in that apartment. Nas was just beginning to take off. His pops used to live near me in Harlem. His dad introduced him to a whole lot of, you know,
有意识的东西，他造就了一个年轻的神童。无论哪个时代，《Drink Champs》都会为你带来最大牌的人物和最无过滤的对话。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《Drink Champs》。好了，如果朝九晚五的想法让你感到彻底空虚，正如我所说，你有两个选项：淡化你的朝九晚五，或者寻找替代方案。我们从第一点开始。
conscious stuff and he made a young prodigy. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect podcast network on the iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Okay, if the idea of the 9 to 5 is leaving you feeling entirely empty, as I said, you have two options. Decentre your 9 to 5 or find an alternative. We're going to start with number one.
即使你不是为朝九晚五的生活方式而生的，并且你认同我们刚才谈到的那些人格类型之一，基于你所选择的事业，甚至可能是你热爱的事业，这也可能是不可避免的。基于你目前的人生阶段，这也可能是不可避免的。我认为对于许多二十多岁的人来说，朝九晚五可能不是永远的，但它是为了当下建立你的职业生涯所必需的。为了避免被它压垮，我们必须努力加强我们工作之外的个性、兴趣和生活，
Even if you aren't made for the 9 to 5 lifestyle and you identify with one of those personality types we just spoke about, it may just be unavoidable based on what you've chosen to do, maybe even what you love to do. It may also be unavoidable just based on the time you're at in your life. I think for a lot of people in their 20s, the 9 to 5 may not be forever, but it is for right now in order to establish your career. To avoid feeling crushed by it, we have to work on strengthening our out-of-work personality, interests, and life
使其在震级上比我们的职场个性、兴趣和生活更大、更令人印象深刻。这就是我们要做的。第一，我们需要在生活的两个不同侧面之间划清界限，几乎是物理上的。我们可以通过创造任何一种仪式来实现这一点，在工作日的开始和结束时向我们的大脑发出信号，表明我们正在从生活的一部分切换到另一部分。其中的一些例子包括：一放工就洗澡，特别是如果你在家工作的话；在离开工作前总是换衣服；在结束一天的工作后总是去散步；合上笔记本电脑，把它拉上拉链收起来，如果可以的话把它留在工作地点，如果你在家工作，把它放在一个特定的位置；听同一首歌、同一张专辑，诸如此类的任何事情，
to be seismically bigger and more impressive than our workplace, personality, interests, and life. this is what we're going to do. Number one, we need to delineate between the two different sides of our life, almost physically. And we can do that by creating any kind of ritual that signals to our brain that we are switching from one part of our life to the other at the beginning and end of the workday. Some examples of that are always having a shower as soon as you finish work, especially if you work from home, always changing your clothes before you leave work, always going for a walk after you finish the day, shutting your laptop, zipping it away, leaving it at work if you can, if you work from home, putting it in a specific location, listening to the same song, same album, anything like that,
你只需要向大脑发出信号，好的，这一天的任务完成了，我们要切换到生活的另一个领域，我们的个人生活。这些听起来可能真的很小、很简单，但从心理学上讲，拥有这种实体边界很重要，因为大脑在进行模式和身份切换时严重依赖语境线索。本质上，如果没有清晰的转变，你的神经系统将很难区分工作模式和个人生活模式，特别是当我们的许多人在家工作或在下班后仍必须保持数字连接时。已经有研究探讨了角色转换理论（role transition theory），尤其是针对在充满压力的环境中工作的人，
you just need to signal to your brain, okay, like we are done with that for the day, we are switching to this other area of our life, our personal life. And they sound really small and simple, but psychologically having that kind of kind of physical boundary is important because the brain relies heavily on contextual cues to mode and identity switch. Essentially, without a clear transition, your nervous system struggles to distinguish between work mode and personal life mode, especially when so many of us work from home or we just have to be digitally connected after hours. There's been this research into role transition theory, especially around people who work in high pressure environments,
比如急诊室、监狱、警察局，研究表明，拥有这种线索有助于减少情绪溢出，因为他们在职业身份和个人身份之间有这种认知上的分离。不过你必须始终如一地这样做。如果你不把它变成常规，它是不会有注册效果的，但这是将工作与家庭分开的最初、最简单的方法之一。第二，通过确保你在工作之外有你真正关心并为之努力的事情，来小心角色纠缠（role inmeshment）。我认为我们二十多岁的时候，职业身份变成我们唯一的身份的风险最大，因为我们对这个新环境来说有点像是初来乍到。
like emergency rooms, prisons, policing, and it shows that having this kind of cue helps reduce emotional spillover because they have that cognitive separation between their professional identity and their personal identity. You have to be consistent with it though. It's not going to register if you don't make it a routine, but that is like one of the first easiest ways to separate work from home. Number two, be careful of role in meshment by making sure that you have things you genuinely care about and are working towards outside of work. Think our 20s are when we are most at risk of our professional identity, becoming our only identity, because we're kind of like fresh to this new environment.
我们还没有真正学会像比我们年长的人那样掌握平衡的艺术。老实说，我认为，或者我可以这样说，朝九晚五生活的初期是非常浪漫的。它真的很有趣。这有点像重新开始大学生活的初期。你和每个人都是朋友，你努力工作，有免费零食，所以很容易觉得：这太棒了，太有趣了，太浪漫了。不过，我们可不想等到为时已晚才离开。摆脱角色纠缠的最大解药就是爱好。
We haven't really learnt like the balancing act that people older than us have. And I honestly think, well, I can say that like the beginning of 9 to 5 life, it's very romantic. It's really fun. It's kind of like being in the start of from uni again. like you're friends with everybody, you're working hard, there's free snacks, like, it's very easy to be like, this is great, this is so fun, this is so romantic. We don't want to leave it until it's too late, though. The biggest antidote to role in meshment is hobbies.
如果你没有一件能够真正说出自己充满热情并喜欢在工作之外或生存所需之外去做的事情，你精疲力竭的可能性就会急剧增加。我们都听说过那个统计数据，即你需要五个爱好：一个用来保持健康，一个用来积累知识，一个用来激发创造力，一个用来保持理智，还有一个用来赚钱。刚开始时，只需选择其中两个类别即可。如果你在寻找自己真正喜欢的东西时遇到困难，或者如果你发现典型的爱好对你来说有点无聊，我认为寻找你个人会觉得有趣的东西的核心途径，是回到你童年时最热爱的事物，那时你拥有最纯粹的好奇心、渴望和兴趣。
If you don't have something that you can genuinely say like you're passionate about and enjoy doing beyond your job or beyond what needs to be done to survive, your likelihood of burnout out is dramatically higher. We've all heard the statistic that you need five hobbies, one to stay fit, one to build knowledge, one to spark creativity, one to keep you sane and want to make you money. Just choose two of those categories to begin with. And if you're struggling with what you'd actually enjoy, like, or if you find that like typical hobbies are like a bit boring to you, I think the central route to finding what you would personally find interesting is going back to what you loved as a child when you're, you just had the most purest kind of curiosity, desire and interest.
另外，不要害怕放弃一个爱好，处于一种“爱好约会”的阶段。我喜欢跑步。我喜欢在周日的三个小时里慢跑穿过伦敦或无论我在哪里的任何地方。但我知道对于很多人来说，这听起来太糟糕了。听起来没有什么比这更糟的了。关键是要享受它。如果你没有享受，列出25件你想尝试的不同事情并去尝试。把它作为一个每周一次的优先事项：你要尝试，你要和这些爱好中的每一个“约会”，直到你找到一个契合的。基本上，这样做就是在一定程度上外包你的身份，将你的热情外包给工作以外的事情。
Also, don't be afraid to, like, abandon a hobby and be in, like, a hobby dating stage. I love running. I love spending, like, three hours on a Sunday jogging around London or wherever I am. But I know for a lot of people, like, that sounds awful. That sounds like there's nothing worse. The point is to enjoy it. And if you're not, make a list of, like, 25 different things you want to try and go at it. Make it a priority once a week. you're going to try, you're going to date each of these hobbies until you find a match. Basically, what this is doing is outsourcing your identity a little bit more, outsourcing your passion to something beyond work.
与之类似，每周的每个晚上，或者至少某些晚上，要做一些特定的事情。特别是，我会说每周有两到三天，你应该安排一些事情，而不是仅仅回家然后做别的事。类似于五种爱好的规则，我喜欢“三个晚上”的规则。每周你需要一个晚上留给自己做点什么，一个晚上和朋友做点什么，一个晚上为自我发展做点什么。这是通过强迫自己刻意用其他事情填满日程，来将新鲜感重新注入朝九晚五的单调生活中的一种方法。
In a similar vein, have specific things that you do each night of the week, or at least some nights of the week. In particular, I would say like two to three days per week, you should have something on where you're not just going home and you're going and doing things. similar to the rule of five hobbies, I like the idea of the rule of three evenings. Every week you need one evening to do something with yourself, one evening to do something with your friends, one evening to do something for your development. This is about injecting novelty back into the monotony of the nine to five routine by forcing yourself to fill your calendar deliberately with other things.
还有一个规则，本集的重大规则，但另一个有助于将新鲜感带回全职工作枯燥生活中的是2-2-2规则。有趣的是，这个技巧其实是我从两性关系维护研究中偷师来的。它说每两周，你必须出去度过一个新奇有趣的夜晚。每两个月，你必须出去过周末。每两年，你必须出去度过两周。两周一个月，诸如此类。记不太清了。
One more rule, big rule episode, but another one that helps bring novel back into the boringness of full-time work is the rule of 2-2-2. This is, funnily enough, a tip I actually stole from relationship maintenance research. It says every two weeks, you've got to go out for a novel fun evening. Every two months, you have to go away for a weekend. Every two years, you have to go away for two weeks. Two weeks a month, something like that. Can't remember.
这招的绝妙之处在于——是的，它显然源于关系治疗——但它的绝妙之处在于你有了期盼。对朝九晚五的悲观情绪有一部分是因为当我们想象未来时，它看起来极其像现在，也极其像不久前的过去。而这种期望和期待的丧失也意味着好奇心和乐观主义的丧失。我知道这可能会让人觉得，天哪，我必须遵守所有这些规则。过上一种我真正享受的生活是一场硬仗。但它确实管用。而且我认为，让朝九晚五不是你生活中唯一的现存结构，才是你如何为生活带回意义的方式，因为它不是唯一的优先级。它不是主导力量。最后，在我们进入“我是不是该直接辞职”的建议之前，
The brilliance of this, yes, obviously it comes from relationship therapy, but the brilliance of this is that you have something to look forward to. Part of the pessimism around the 9 to 5 is that when we imagine the future, it looks awfully like the present and awfully a lot like the near past. And that loss of expectation and anticipation also means a loss of curiosity and optimism. I know it can feel like, God, I have to have all these rules. It's an upward battle to like have a life that I actually enjoy. But it does work. And I think having the 9 to 5 not be the only present structure in your life is how you bring back meaning to your life because it is not the only priority. It is not the dominant force. Finally, before we get into the, should I just quit
你需要真正评估你对自己是否有愿景，以及你为什么要这份工作。朝九晚五的日常中最困难的部分之一并不总是工作本身，正如我们一直在说的。那种觉得你的生活是在为某种毫无意义的事物服务的感受。心理学家称之为目标不一致（goal incongruence）。当你的日常行动、身份、目标等与你实际觉得你想做或应得的事情处于不和谐状态时，就会出现这种情况。当大脑出现这种目标不一致时，它对压力、无聊、重复和延迟满足的耐受力就会大大降低。
advice, you need to genuinely assess whether you have a vision for yourself and why you're doing this job. One of the hardest parts of the 9 to 5 routine isn't always the work itself, as we've been saying. It's the feeling that your life is happening in service of something meaningless. Psychologists call this goal incongruence. It's when your daily actions, identity, purpose, whatever, it's in a state of disharmony with what you actually feel you want to do or deserve to do. Your brain, when it has that goal in congruence, is far less able to tolerate stress, boredom, repetition, delayed gratification.
2018年发表在《心理学前沿》（Frontiers of Psychology）杂志上的一项研究发现，那些工作能带给他们以下感受的人：A，更广泛的宗旨，即他们觉得自己在做某种追求更大善意的事情，或者有一个他们在努力实现的最大善意，或者B，赋予他们自我实现感，基本上就是自主性、真实性和自我表达的感觉。他们不仅对工作与生活平衡感觉更好，对生活本身也感觉更好。你的工作提供了这两者中的任何一个吗——更广泛的宗旨，或者成就感或自我实现感？你必须认真地问自己：为什么我要做这份工作？这是一个令人满意的理由吗？
There was a 2018 study published in the journal, frontiers of psychology and they found that people whose jobs gave them A, a broader purpose in that they felt they were doing some kind of greater good or there was a greater good they were striving for or B gave them self-realization, basically a sense of autonomy, authenticity, self-expression. They felt better not just about their work-life balance, but about their lives. Does your job provide either of those two things, a broader purpose or a sense of self-fulfillment or self-realization? You have to seriously ask yourself, like, why am I doing this job and is it a satisfying reason?
是因为稳定性吗？是因为机会吗？是因为它能让你为他人做些什么吗？是因为它令人印象深刻吗？是因为它恰好是你申请的第一份工作而你碰巧得到了它吗？是因为你大学里的每个人都进入了这个学科吗？你也就跟着他们去吧。为什么？
Is it because of stability? Is it because of opportunities? Is it because of what it allows you to do for others? Is it because it's impressive? Is it because it was just the first job you applied for and you happened to get it? Is it because everybody else at your uni was going into this discipline? You may as well follow them. Why?
你为什么要这样做？如果这个理由还不够，那么再强调一次，没有任何生活方式的改变能解决这个问题。因为每周花40小时做一件你觉得毫无意义的事情是很难轻易扭转的。所以，这就是我们得出对话中“也许我需要离开这里”这一观点的时候。这里我指的不仅是工作，还有朝九晚五的生活方式。首先要考虑的是，在冲动行事之前，在你辞职之前，有没有办法以不同的形式去做你喜欢的工作部分？比如自由职业、轮班工作。有没有办法专注于你喜欢的工作的那一部分，并以一种
Why are you doing this? And if that reason isn't enough, once again, no lifestyle change is going to fix that. because doing something you feel has no meaning for 40 hours a week is not easily reversible. So this is when we arrive at the maybe I need to just get out of here point of this conversation. And by here I mean not just the job, but like the 9 to 5 lifestyle. First thing to consider, before you jump the gun, is there a way that you can do the parts of your job that you love in a different format before you quit? So like freelance, shift work. Is there a way that you can hone in on the one part of the job that you like and do that in a
专业化的方式来做？我认为在转换道路之前踏上平行轨道显然是一种可能性。其次，有没有任何方法能以一种令人满意的方式来做这份工作？在冒险改变整个结构之前，尝试这条道路你会冒什么样的险？我认为它最终归结为一个成本效益分析，你知道的，如果我再次拥有70个美好的地球年华，我只有一次生命，我正处于二十多岁，我拥有前所未有的自由，如果我对自己诚实的话，我并不是很开心，我会继续吗？我应该继续选择这个吗？我是否会为自己选择这个？
specialized way? I think jumping onto parallel tracks before diverting the path is obviously a possibility. Secondly, is there just any way of doing this job in a way that is satisfying? What would you risk by trying out that path before you risked the entire structure? I think it does eventually come down to a cost-benefit analysis of, you know, if I've, again, 70 good years on the earth and I have one life and I'm in my 20s and I have more freedom than I ever will and if I'm being honest with myself, I'm not very happy like would I continue, should I continue to choose this? Not should I keep doing this. Would I choose this for myself every
独特的方式？我认为在分流之前跳上平行的轨道显然是一种可能。其次，有没有什么方法可以以一种令人满意的方式来做这份工作？在冒险整个结构之前，尝试这条道路会冒什么样的风险？我认为这最终归结为一个成本效益分析，你知道，如果我再次在地球上有70个美好的年头，我有一条生命，我二十多岁，我拥有比以往任何时候都多的自由，如果我对诚实自己，我不是很开心，就像我会继续吗，我应该继续选择这个吗？不是我应该继续这样做吗。我会为自己选择这个每一次
day from now? What are the pro cons of that? I think it will feel very scary to to walk away from something stable. But this is something we often miss when we sit down and do a pro cons list of like, do I stay or do I go? Do I change? Do I stay the same? We underestimate. We don't properly assign the frustration and hopelessness of the years ahead of us and the cumulative load of that satisfaction. We often just account for our unhappiness right now. We think it's going to pass. And it doesn't. It just turns into apathy and resentment. We underestimate that and we overestimate the difficulty, specifically the emotional difficulty of this leap of faith. There is this amazing psychological model called the Roller Coaster of Change.
从今天算起呢？利弊是什么？我觉得离开一些稳定的事情会让人感到非常害怕。但这是我们在坐下来列利弊清单时经常忽略的一点，比如：我是留下来还是离开？我是该改变还是保持现状？我们低估了。我们没有正确评估未来几年的挫败感和绝望感，以及这种不满意感日积月累的负担。我们往往只计算了我们眼前的痛苦。我们以为它会过去的。但它并没有。它只是变成了冷漠和怨恨。我们低估了这一点，而高估了这种信仰之跃的困难，尤其是情感上的困难。有一个非常棒的心理学模型叫做“变化的过山车”。
It was developed by Elizabeth Huberl Ross. She's a Swiss psychiatrist. And it talks about how we're going to feel our worst about a decision the moment that we make it. As we realize, you know, we need to let go. There's nothing left for me here. We're disorientated. We're angry. That's when we're going to feel really bad.
它是由伊丽莎白·库伯勒·罗斯（Elizabeth Kübler-Ross）开发的。她是一位瑞士精神病学家。它讨论了我们在做出决定的那一刻，对该决定的感受会糟糕到极点。当我们意识到，你知道，我们需要放手。这里已经没有什么值得我留恋的了。我们感到迷失方向。我们感到愤怒。那是我们感觉最糟糕的时候。
we say, oh my God, I realize I need to change is when we're going to feel the most intensely. But it's also when you get to work. And as soon as you're at that low point, she assumes, she says things do improve as you move through these other stages of exploration, purpose, problem solving. All of these activities of rediscovery will alone re-engage a part of your brain that you previously probably weren't using very much. So you will begin to feel a sense of meaning and purpose coming back into your life, even if it is scary, because you have something that you meaningfully feel you are working towards, even if the outcome is unknown. If your next question is, okay, what do I do instead? I actually don't know what I want to do. This is a very simple
当我们说：“天哪，我意识到我需要改变”时，正是我们感受最强烈的时候。但这也是你开始行动的时候。一旦你处于那个低谷，她认为，随着你经历探索、目标、解决问题等其他阶段，情况会有所改善。所有这些重新发现的活动本身，就会重新激活你大脑中以前可能没有怎么使用过的一部分。因此，你将开始感觉到意义和目标重新回到你的生活中，即使这很吓人，因为你有一些你觉得很有意义、正在努力去实现的目标，哪怕结果是未知的。如果你接下来的问题是：好吧，那我该做什么呢？我其实不知道我想做什么。这是一个非常简单的
exercise that may be able to reveal that for you. It consists of, I think it's like four or five questions. The first, what task do I naturally find myself engaged in without even trying? Basically, where does my flow state come from? What do I enjoy? Secondly, what do people naturally come to me for help with? What does that kind of reveal about what you are naturally good at? How important is money to you and how important is purpose? If you're being very honest, would you be willing to sacrifice one for the other? In 10 years' time, how do you picture your ideal workday?
练习，也许能为你揭晓答案。它包含，我想大概是四五个问题。第一，我自然而然会全身心投入，甚至不需要刻意去做的任务是什么？基本上，我的心流状态来自哪里？我喜欢什么？第二，人们通常会主动找我寻求什么帮助？这在某种程度上揭示了你天生擅长什么？钱对你有多重要，目标对你有多重要？如果你非常诚实，你愿意为了其中一个而牺牲另一个吗？在10年后的未来，你理想的工作日是怎么样的？
When are you getting up? Where are you working? Are you in an office? Are you surrounded by people? Are you outdoors? Are you doing deep work, busy work, creative work, physical work? What does it look like? How do you feel?
你什么时候起床？你在哪里工作？你在办公室吗？你周围都是人吗？你在户外吗？你在做深度工作、琐事、创意工作、体力工作？它是什么样子的？你感觉如何？
And in 50 years' time, what will you be most proud to say that you have done that you haven't yet accomplished? What do you keep coming back to here? I had a professor say to me once, your purpose isn't that hard to find. It is the thing you think about every day, but talk yourself out of every night. if you think it's your calling I don't think it ever stops calling but you get very good at ignoring it
在50年后的未来，你做过什么事会让你感到最骄傲，而这件事你现在还没完成？你在这里一直反复想到的是什么？我曾听一位教授对我说过：你的目标并不难找。它就是你每天都在想，但每天晚上又说服自己放弃的东西。如果你认为那是你的使命，我认为它永远不会停止呼唤你，但你却变得非常擅长忽视它。
if you don't pick up after the first few rings I think deep down you know you know what you want to do now it's worth examining like why am I afraid really stop and think for a second like what is that deep fear keeping you in this unhappy place is it that you'll never be enough
如果你在前几声铃响后没有接听，我想你内心深处其实知道，你知道自己现在想做什么。现在值得思考的是：为什么我害怕？真的停下来想一想，比如：究竟是什么深层的恐惧让你留在这个痛苦的地方？是因为你觉得自己永远不够好吗？
is it that you'll fail that people will be mad at you embarrassed for you that they'll see you trying and that will be whatever cringe. I think it comes down to two separate problems. The first is a practicality problem. The second is an ego problem. And they're different and they need to be addressed in different ways. We're going to talk about how after this final short break. Pride Month Toronto. Pride is an opportunity for you to create your own space to celebrate your existence. IHartRadio is proud to be an official sponsor of Pride Toronto.
是因为你会失败吗？别人会对你生气、为你感到尴尬吗？他们会看到你在尝试，然后觉得这一切都很尴尬吗？我认为这归结为两个独立的问题。第一个是实际问题。第二个是自我问题。它们是不同的，需要用不同的方式去解决。在最后这段简短的广告之后，我们将讨论如何解决。多伦多自豪月。自豪月为你提供了一个创造专属空间来庆祝你存在的机会。iHeartRadio 很荣幸能成为多伦多自豪月的官方赞助商。
festival and we won't stop celebrate pride turn up the love and listen to iHeart pride Canada your 24-7 radio stream and the only playlist you need for your Toronto Pride celebrations pride is so great because it gives a whole bunch of people this visibility that they've never had before we have a ton to celebrate Toronto happy pride Iheart radio in the moment it felt like it was going on forever I didn't think I was going to live I was terrified There was no anything inside those eyes.
这个节日，我们将继续庆祝自豪月，传递爱意，收听 iHeart 24/7 全天候电台直播的加拿大 iHeart 自豪月频道，这是你多伦多自豪月庆祝活动唯一需要的播放列表。自豪月之所以如此伟大，是因为它让许多从未获得过这种关注的人群被看见。我们有太多值得庆祝的事情，多伦多自豪月快乐！iHeartRadio，在那个当下，感觉仿佛过了一个世纪，我以为我活不成了，我吓坏了。那些眼神里没有任何东西。
They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets.
它们变成了黑色。把我吓死。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，长官。可以说这是你职业生涯中最大的案子吗？是的，长官。对一个孩子的强奸和谋杀。简直是罪大恶极。
I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app,
我想是的。人们醒醒吧。我就是那个看到克里瓦克（Crevette）和德皮波（DePippo）谋杀过程的人。安东尼·德皮波（Anthony DePippo）没有表现出任何悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得无动于衷。我说我没有罪。我至死也不会认罪。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world. most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer,
Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《恶魔采石场》（The Devil's Quarry）。要想无广告收听《恶魔采石场》并获得独家内容，请在 Apple Podcasts 上订阅 Love for Good Plus。嘿，我是荷妲·柯特比（Hoda Kotb），播客《荷妲·柯特比的快乐101》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby）的主持人。我们将与世界上最迷人的人展开有意义的对话。就像当女演员奥利维亚·穆恩（Olivia Munn）分享她如何战胜严峻的健康挑战时一样。我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮我母亲战胜了乳腺癌，
and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And it's an ton of exciting because their new star is Javier Tichorino Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born.
而那更加困难。有很多人理解产后抑郁症。但我对产后焦虑毫无准备。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听由荷妲·柯特比主持的《快乐 101》。这让人非常兴奋，因为他们的新星是哈维尔·“奇查里托”·埃尔南德斯（Javier "Chicharito" Hernandez）。每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情绪共处，从我出生起就是这样。
And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barcelona?
而且我仍然有那么多问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何应对被取消？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴塞罗那？
From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your close. as friends where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and everything is just. Wait-in me, I'm here to put me going to be able to be able to be
从日常生活中的平凡到深刻而非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像是与你亲密朋友的一次深度谈话，脆弱感表露无遗。阴谋论被摆上台面，目标和人生经验得以分享。这世间的一切都有完美的秩序，一切皆是公正。等等我，我在这里，我将能够，能够
connect. The Chicharito. And together with IHA Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary, stay close. It's a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
连接。我是奇查里托。我们将与 iHeartRadio 一起，将平凡化为非凡，敬请期待。这真是太棒了。在 iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《学习做人》（Learning to Be Human）。
Keith Gianmanca seemed like a mild-mannered suburban dad, but secretly he became someone else, a master of disguise who went on a crime spree. At the time, did it seem like a crazy idea? It seemed very crazy, but I felt so desperate that I felt it was the quickest, easiest way out. Did you allow yourself to think about how it could go wrong and what that might look like?
基思·吉安曼卡（Keith Gianmanca）看起来像一个温和的郊区父亲，但私底下他变成了另一个人——一个精通伪装、疯狂作案的犯罪分子。当时，这听起来像是个疯狂的主意吗？这听起来非常疯狂，但我当时感到如此绝望，以至于我觉得这是最快、最简单的出路。你有没有让自己去想，事情可能会出错，那会是什么样子？
No. I didn't want to manifest that. I was trying to manifest success. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. This is going to change my life and my family dynamic forever
没有。我不想去想那些不好的结果。我只想吸引成功。每个家庭都有秘密。但是，当你发现你的父亲过着双重生活时，会发生什么？那可不是一个无辜之人的眼神。这将永远改变我的生活和我的家庭动态，
because everything that had existed prior in my reality is now untrue. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man. the iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So when it comes to making the decision to leave your nine to five behind, addressing the problem of ego is first. And it means being okay with not being able to control how people perceive you because of your choices.
因为我现实生活中先前的存在的一切现在都不真实了。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《深层卧底：顾家男人》（Deep Cover: The Family Man）。因此，当谈到决定抛弃朝九晚五的工作时，首先要解决的是自我意识（Ego）问题。这意味着你要接受这样一个事实：因为你的选择，你无法控制别人如何看待你。
There is going to be judgment. There's probably going to be a lot of fear from people who love you that's going to look like judgment. What we have to return to as our why. Over and over again, why am I doing this? Why is this important to me? I think you know your answer. It's important to you because you don't believe you deserve to be unhappy,
肯定会有评判。爱你的人可能会产生很多恐惧，而这种恐惧看起来就像是指责和评判。我们必须回归我们的“初心”。一次又一次地问：我为什么要这么做？这对为什么我很重要？我想你知道答案。它对你很重要，是因为你认为自己不应该过得不快乐，
because you want more, because you know you have a calling, because you know yourself. You think and you believe and you have to believe that work can be enjoyable, because you have to try. That's your why. Everybody has one. And a 2021 study found that having a why behind a major life decision or change, that you can put into a single statement and point to and say, this is why I'm doing this, it greatly impacts your follow through, greatly impacts your perseverance, your success,
因为你想要更多，因为你知道自己有使命，因为你了解自己。你认为、你相信，并且你必须相信工作是可以令人愉快的，因为你必须去尝试。这就是你的初心。每个人都有。2021年的一项研究发现，当重大生活决策或改变背后有一个“初心”，并且你能把它浓缩成一句话，明确指出“这就是我做这件事的原因”时，它会极大地影响你的执行力、极大地影响你的毅力和成功率。
and remind yourself, like, you're not without backup options. You've already done plan B. Like a lot of people go in with Plan A and don't have Plan B sorted out. You've done Plan B. You went back to front. There is no, like, issue in that you couldn't eventually return to that job that you're going to leave. That's always going to be there. you've done the training you've got the you've done the degree you've got the work experience like
提醒自己，比如：你并不是没有备选方案。你已经执行了B计划。就像很多人带着A计划上路，却没理清B计划一样。你已经做好了B计划。你把顺序倒过来了。并没有什么问题，你最终还是可以回到你要辞掉的那份工作上去。那一直都在。你完成了培训，你有，你拿到了学位，你有工作经验，
you are in a better position than many to now take a risk because you do have fallback I also think we need to be aware of like a lot of the time the judgment that we think or know will come from other people is really just desire that they have that can't be expressed they are looking at your choice, your decision, and it's easier to say that's going to fail or to say, what are they thinking, then to acknowledge what this person is really thinking deep down, which is that why don't I have the guts to do that? And the fear that maybe it will end up turning out really well for you, and they're going to have to face the fact that it could have turned out really well for them as well.
相比许多人，你处于更有利的地位去承担风险，因为你确实有退路。我也认为我们需要意识到，很多时候，我们以为或知道会来自其他人的评判，其实只是他们内心深处无法表达的欲望。他们看着你的选择、你的决定，说那会失败或者说“他们在想什么呢”，这比去承认这个人内心深处真正想的是什么要容易得多——那就是：为什么我没有勇气那样做？他们害怕也许结果对你来说会非常好，而他们将不得不面对这样一个事实：这其实对他们来说也可以结果很好的现实。
So just be conscious of why and how other people's opinions about your choice is probably more of a reflection of them than of you. Next is the practicality problem. As someone who has quit their 9 to 5 for this very podcast, I want to tell you some things to be prepared for. I think we definitely glamorized quitting the 9 to 5 grind because, of course we do. Like unless you're part of the 25% who are made for that lifestyle, like there are challenges and you're going to be unhappy.
所以，只需清醒地认识到，为什么以及其他人对你的选择的看法，可能更多是他们自己的反映，而不是对你的评价。接下来是实际问题。作为为了这个播客而辞掉朝九晚五工作的人，我想告诉你一些需要做好准备的事情。我认为我们绝对美化了辞去朝九晚五枯燥工作这件事，因为我们当然会这么做。除非你是那种天生适合那种生活方式的25%的人，否则那里确实有挑战，而且你会感到不快乐。
But there are also challenges with the like, I quit my 9 to 5 and I've never been more fulfilled lifestyle that we see. And things that you probably wouldn't think about. The first one, which you probably do know, is that it's very expensive. They do tell you this, I will say. But I just think, practically speaking, you need to be prepared for a lifestyle adjustment. So I personally had, from memory, like three to four months of expenses saved up. And I did have my, like, door back into my nine to five that I was very grateful for.
但我们在网上看到的“我辞去了朝九晚五的工作，从未感到如此充实”的生活方式，其实也有它自己的挑战。还有一些你可能不会想到的事情。第一点，你可能也知道，那就是这非常昂贵。他们确实会告诉你这一点，我得承认。但我只是觉得，从实际角度来看，你需要为生活方式的调整做好准备。就我个人而言，根据记忆，我大概存了三到四个月的生活费。而且我很感激自己还留有一条能回到朝九晚五工作岗位的后路。
It was still a risk. The risk was worth it for me. just because something is a risk though doesn't mean it needs to be spontaneous and so I really took as much time as I could to prepare save save save again build alongside your nine to five for as long as you can if you can and have a bit of a squirrel mentality you know how squirrels like berry hide their food hide their nuts to survive the winter I did that as well before I quit my nine to five in the six months kind of leading up to me quitting I would yes I was saving but I was also like putting money onto an emergency debit card that I then put away for a rainy day that I didn't have
这仍然是一个风险。但对我来说，这个风险是值得的。不过，一件事是风险并不意味着它需要是冲动的。所以我真的花了我能用的所有时间来准备、存钱、存钱、再存钱。只要你能够做到，就尽可能地在你的朝九晚五工作之余进行积累。有点像松鼠的心态，你知道松鼠是如何把食物藏起来、把坚果藏起来以度过冬天的吗？我在辞去朝九晚五的工作之前也这么做了。在我辞职前的六个月左右，我确实在存钱，但我也把钱存进一张应急借记卡里，然后把卡收起来，留作不时之需，我是没法
access to. I also got my car appraised so I knew what that was worth and what I was working with. I also picked up tutoring work and I got paid in cash and I wouldn't spend that money and I would hide it away so that like on a rainy day it was there. The squirrel mentality was really helpful as well because it stopped me from feeling like this was going to be a disaster and then I was going to fall flat on my face financially. Like I felt like there were different levels that I would drop to when I knew like, oh my God, maybe this isn't working out. And I was so lucky that, you know, it all did work out and I never had to use a lot of those things. But again, a lot of it was psychological and then I felt like I had the safety net. The second thing they don't tell you. And as a
动用那些钱的。我还给我的车做了估价，所以我知道它值多少钱以及我能动用多少资金。我还接了一些家教工作，拿的是现金，我不会花那些钱，而是把它们藏起来，这样在艰难的日子里钱就在那儿。松鼠的心态也非常有用，因为它让我不再觉得这将是一场灾难，然后我会在经济上摔得粉身碎骨。我觉得我会有不同的经济承受底线，即使我知道，天哪，也许这行不通。我很幸运，这一切最终都行之有效，我从来没有动用过很多那些储备。但话说回来，很大程度上是心理层面的作用，让我觉得自己有了安全网。他们没告诉你的第二件事。作为一个
pathological extrovert, I wish that somebody had said this. It is very, very lonely. you quit your nine to five, there is this period of like elation and excitement and like you're pursuing your dreams and you're building something and you're trying something new. Unless you have friends who are also doing that or you have friends in like creative industries or who run their own businesses, a lot of the time you're like, I am waiting. I'm going to spend my whole time waiting for somebody to also clock off from their nine to five so that we can hang out. And it can, it's a very unique situation to be in to feel like, oh, no, Nobody else really knows what I'm going through, but also I chose this.
病态的外向者，我希望当时有人能告诉我：这真的、真的很孤独。你辞去了朝九晚五的工作，会经历一段欣喜和兴奋的时期，仿佛你在追求梦想、在构建某些东西、在尝试新鲜事物。除非你有同样在做这件事的朋友，或者你在创意行业或经营自己的企业有这样的朋友，否则很多时候你会想：我在等待。我要花所有的精力和时间去等待别人也从朝九晚五的工作中下班，这样我们才能一起出去玩。这是一种非常独特的处境，你会觉得，哦，不，没有人真正理解我正在经历什么，但这也是我自己的选择。
I wish I just would have a friend in this. It can be quite an isolating thing. And the third thing is boundaries. If you thought you didn't have boundaries at your 9 to 5, pursuing a big dream, working for yourself, pursuing something, I don't know, creative or a business, you will have less boundaries there because now you are the boss, the employee, the accounting department, HR, social media, you're everybody. And you're not just doing this for somebody else.
我希望身边能有个朋友懂这种感受。这可能是一件相当孤立的事情。第三件事是边界感。如果你以为你在朝九晚五的工作中没有边界感，那么去追求一个宏大的梦想、为自己打工、追求某种创意或商业项目，你在那里将会有更少的边界感。因为现在你既是老板、员工，又是会计部门、人力资源、社交媒体运营，你一个人扮演所有人。而且你不仅是在为别人做这件事，
you're doing this for you. It all counts. Like your input is directly correlated to the output. And yes, there's a bit of luck kind of thrown in there. But with the traditional job, like, you're a team and there's somebody else who can help you. There's also somebody else that you can kind of blame. You are going to work much harder. Unless you were like a doctor or like in finance or in a very high-pressure job, I would say nine out of ten. times, you're going to work longer, more intense hours on this new path. Again, it's worth it because you get the full impact of that output. You don't have to share it. And also, I think the dedication and motivation is much more accessible than it is when you're working for somebody else.
你是在为自己做这件事。所有的付出都算数。比如你的投入与产出是直接挂钩的。是的，其中难免带有一点运气的成分。但在传统的工作中，你是一个团队，还有其他人可以帮你。也有其他人可以让你去怪罪。你将会付出更多、更努力的工作。除非你是医生、金融从业人员或从事压力极大的工作，否则十有八九，在这条新道路上，你会工作更长时间、强度更高。再次强调，这是值得的，因为你能获得产出的全部收益。你不需要跟别人分。而且，我认为这种奉献精神和动力比你为别人打工时要容易获得得多。
Perhaps psychologically, because you have a clearer vision and your goal is clear, you know what you want, you know what you're after, it's there, this is for you. But be warned. There are some just other considerations. So some things to include in your I want to quit my nine to five plan. Make sure you know what your explicit vision is for why you're doing this. Can you see it? Can you write it? Can you think about it? Can you feel it? What are three things that you're going to do in the first week, first month, first three months to execute that vision? Make sure you have practical steps? Have you thought about how you're going to manage money, how you're going to manage connection and how you're going to manage boundaries? Are you willing to do? Are you willing to
也许在心理上，因为你有更清晰的远景，目标也很明确，你知道自己想要什么，你在追求什么，它就在那里，这是为你自己而做的。但请注意。还有其他一些需要考量的事情。因此，在你的“我想辞去朝九晚五”的计划中，有一些事情需要包括进去：确保你清楚地知道你为什么要这样做的明确远景。你能看见它吗？你能把它写下来吗？你能去思考它吗？你能去感受它吗？为了实现这个远景，你在第一周、第一个月、前三个月要做的三件事是什么？确保你有切实可步骤！你有没有想过如何管理资金、如何管理人际关系、如何管理边界感？你愿意这样做吗？你愿意
to sacrifice things in that department, I'm hoping your answer is yes. And what is the backup plan that doesn't require you to go back to your nine to five? I think you can have two backup plans, right? The nine to five is always going to be there. The effort that you put into that is always going to be there. What's your other plan for this more I work for myself, creative, big dream, independent lifestyle that won't require you to have to have made this big leap and then go all the way back. Maybe just go slightly back. I don't think there's any shame in going back to the drawing board or having that plan B. There's been heaps of times where I've, you know, something wasn't working and I think it's definitely this evolve or die mentality. And that's probably something you were
在这个方面做出牺牲吗？我希望你的回答是肯定的。还有一个不需要让你重新回到朝九晚五工作的备用计划是什么？我想你可以有两个备用计划，对吧？朝九晚五的工作一直都在。你投入到那份工作中的精力也一直都在。对于这种更加“我为自己工作”、富有创造力、追求宏大梦想、独立的生活方式，你的另一个计划是什么，能让你不必非得做出这个巨大的飞跃，然后又一路退回原点？也许只是稍微退一步。我觉得重头再来或者有这个B计划并没有什么羞耻的。有很多次，你知道的，某些事情行不通，我绝对认为这是一种“进化或消亡”的心态。而这可能是你在朝九晚五的
missing in your 9 to 5 evolution. But just be prepared that it's not going to be this easy, glamorous thing that a lot of people talk about online is a struggle, I still think, again, it's worth it. And at the end of the day, you're probably at this point when you have little to lose and a lot to gain, right? The job that you've been doing or are currently doing has already taken all that it can from you. And I think when you get to this very existential point of like, what am I doing this for? What am I here for? What? Like, why? Why? I'm am I wasting my time? There is no pushing through that.
进化中所缺失的东西。但请做好心理准备，这不会像很多人在网上说的那样是一件轻松、光鲜亮丽的事情，这是一场挣扎。但我仍然认为，这一切是值得的。归根结底，你可能正处于这样一个节点：你失去的很少，得到的很多，对吧？你一直在做或目前正在做的工作已经榨干了你的所有价值。我想当你到达这个极具存在主义危机的时刻，比如：“我到底在做什么？我为什么在这里？为什么？为什么？我是在浪费时间吗？”这种状态是无法硬着头皮熬过去的。
The only thing that's on the other side of that is just to become completely switched off and resentful. So if you have even in the slightest capacity, the desire to move beyond this lifestyle, the capability, the financial position, or you could put yourself in a financial position where you should give this a go, I think just even having the experience. experience of three, four, five months of trying is going to be worth so much so that at least you can go back to your nine to five if it doesn't work out and say, hey, but at least I didn't have to sit here for the next 30, 40 years wondering and wishing and thinking, what if, what else,
在那之后唯一的结局，就是变得彻底麻木和怨恨。所以，如果你哪怕有一点点渴望超越这种生活方式的意愿，具备这种能力、财务状况，或者你能让自己处于一种应该去尝试一下的财务状况，我认为哪怕只是去体验三、四个、五个月也是非常值得的。这样如果行不通，你至少可以回到朝九晚五的工作中去说：“嘿，但至少我不用在接下来的30、40年里坐在那里胡思乱想、满心遗憾、想着‘如果当初……’、‘还有什么别的可能’、
what could have been? So that is kind of your guide. In summary, I want to say if you are struggling with your 9 to 5 right now and you are feeling like it is crushing you, you are most certainly not alone. I hear about it all the time because I think this life, the way that it is set up, it's no longer just the 9 to 5. It's so much more than that. It's so time consuming, so crushing in a way that I think, I think that we can't really understand until we're living it. It was made this idea of the 9 to 5 was constructed in a different time and it's okay to want more. and it is possible to have more. I think, again, there are certain personalities for whom the nine to five will never be fulfilling.
‘本来会怎样’。”这就是你的指南。总而言之，我想说的是，如果你现在正在朝九晚五的工作中挣扎，并且觉得它正在压垮你，你绝对不是一个人。我经常听到这样的情况，因为我认为这种生活，以目前这种设立方式，已经不再只是简单的朝九晚五了。它远比这要多得多。它是如此耗费时间，如此具有压迫感，我觉得，这种压迫感在我们真正身处其中之前是无法真正理解的。这种朝九晚五的理念是在一个不同的时代构建的，渴望得到更多是没有错的，
Maybe that is you. And if it is, you have those two options. Either deprioritize your nine to five whilst you're still in it or seek an alternative and take the risk, especially if you're in your 20s, like, why not? Like, obviously, if you have a valid reason, don't take this as like, oh, be disappointed in you or like you're giving up on your dreams because I know it's very complicated and it's not an easy decision. But if the reason is quite paper thin, if it's a bit of a paper wall that you could push down, I think you kind of owe it to yourself to try. So I hope this has been motivating. If you have
而且拥有更多也是可能的。我认为，再次说明，某些个性的人永远无法在朝九晚五中找到充实感。也许你就是这样的人。如果是的话，你就有这两个选择：要么在你还在职的时候降低朝九晚五的优先级，要么寻找替代方案并承担风险，特别是如果你正处于20多岁的年纪，为什么不呢？当然，如果你有正当理由，不要把这当成是对你的失望，或者觉得你在放弃梦想，因为我知道这非常复杂，这不是一个容易的决定。但如果理由相当苍白无力，如果那只是一扇你可以推倒的纸糊的墙，我想你多多少少欠自己一个尝试的机会。所以我希望这能给你带来动力。如果你
made it this far into the episode and you're listening on Spotify, leave a comment down below, what is the life that you want beyond the 9 to 5? What is the dream job? Maybe you don't dream of a labor or dream of a job. dream life that you are looking for beyond this structure. I hope that you find it. I think that you are absolutely capable of doing it. I don't want to like, I sit here and say, oh, because I've done it, you can because I know everybody's circumstances are different. But if you have ever thought, like, is it worth it and will it work out? The answer is yes. And I do think that you owe it to yourself. You can watch this episode on Netflix and all other episodes by following the links in the description. You can read the transcript of this episode on Substack, also available
听到了这一集的末尾，并且正在 Spotify 上收听，请在下方留言：超越朝九晚五，你想要的生活是什么？理想的工作是什么？也许你并不梦想有劳碌，也不梦想有工作。而是超越这个框架，你所寻找的梦想生活是什么？我希望你能找到它。我认为你绝对有能力做到这一点。我不想坐在里说：“哦，因为我做到了，所以你也能做到”，因为我知道每个人的情况都不同。但如果你曾想过：“这值得吗？会成功吗？”答案是肯定的。而且我确实认为你欠自己一个尝试。你可以在 Netflix 上观看本集，也可以通过描述中的链接收听所有其他集数。你可以在 Substack 上阅读本集的文字稿，链接同样在
in the description. Instagram, links to my book, all those things are down there as well if you want to do some exploring. Again, I hope you enjoyed this episode. If you have any further thoughts that you want to share, you can DM me on Instagram and I would be happy to listen to them. But until next time, be safe, be kind. Especially be gentle with yourself if you're finding yourself. Very burnt out by work. I feel you. We will talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black.
描述中。Instagram、我的书的链接，如果你想进行更多探索，所有这些都在下面。再次希望你喜欢这一集。如果你有任何想分享的进一步想法，可以在 Instagram 上私信我，我很高兴倾听。但在此之前，请注意安全，保持善良。如果你发现自己因工作而精疲力竭，请务必对自己温柔一点。我感同身受。我们很快就会再聊。那些眼神里没有任何东西。它们变成了黑色。
It scared the hell out of me. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
把我吓死。人们醒醒吧。我就是那个看到克里瓦克和德皮波谋杀过程的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出任何悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得无动于衷。我说我没有罪。我至死也不会认罪。在 Bone Valley Feed 的 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《恶魔采石场》。
Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now.
快乐至关重要，但它也难以捉摸。不过现在，有一个令人兴奋的新方法来开启你走向更快乐生活的旅程。《快乐 101》（Joy 101）。这是由我——荷妲·柯特比主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的空中聊天。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索 Joy 101 并立即收听。
Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine.
由 CVS 呈现的由荷妲·柯特比主持的《快乐 101》。每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情绪共处，从我出生起就是这样。这不是一个普通播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。
Just honest, conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier El Chicharito Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Your husband is not who you think he is. Your body is not what you thought it was. Your identity is formed by a secret history. I'm Danny Shapiro. And these are just a few of the stunning stories I'll be exploring on the 14th season of Family Secrets. He kind of shoved me out of the way and said, move.
只是关于活着的意义的真诚对话。我是哈维尔·埃尔·奇查里托·埃尔南德斯（Javier El Chicharito Hernandez），在 iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《学习做人》。你的丈夫并不是你想象的那样。你的身体也不是你认为的那样。你的身份是由一段秘密历史塑造的。我是丹妮·夏皮罗（Dani Shapiro）。这些只是我将在《家族秘密》（Family Secrets）第14季中探讨的几个震撼人心的故事。他有点把我推开，说：“让开。”
And he went out the front door and he jumped in a car and drove off. and that was the last time I saw him. Listen to season 14 of Family Secrets on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is,
然后他从前门走出去，跳上一辆车开走了。那就是我最后一次见到他。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《家族秘密》第14季。这里有一件本不该如此复杂的事：拆除种族主义雕像。这里还有一件本该容易得多、
getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit, season two, is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority black city in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people.
却要在原地立起一座新雕像的事。我是阿凯拉·休斯（Akela Hughes），《叛逆精神》（Rebel Spirit）第二季探讨的就是这两件事。当我看着这些雕像倒塌时，我在想，我在一个以黑人为主的城市长大，那里的奴役者纪念碑比被奴役的人的纪念碑还多，这意味着什么。
Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《叛逆精神》第二季。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。